good afternoon and welcome to our midday
briefing in the commission's press room
but also thank you for following us
uh online live on europe by satellite
today 14th of february 2022.
let me start our announcements by giving
you information about the meeting of the
college of commissioners which will take
place
tomorrow in strasbourg
so the college will discuss and will
adopt a series of initiatives in
relation
to space and also a package of
initiatives on defense
both packages will be presented by
commissioner breton following the
college meeting so that will be the
subject of the college
readout at about
15
30 so at 3 30 tomorrow afternoon
after this midday briefing by the way we
are offering to you a technical briefing
on space so on that series of
initiatives that we are
discussing and adopting uh tomorrow in
strasbourg so if you are interested stay
tuned to have that uh package
explained to you
then
on sequi constantly
[Music]
[Music]
so please like always raise your hand if
you have a question for us today
live in the press room and online and
that indeed i see a few hands up and the
first one will be oliver let's try to
get oliver on the line
hi
um
i have a question on the debate in the
ukraine i have a question on the debate
in european parliament on wednesday uh
um that's going to take place at four
it's about the rule of law
conditionality mechanism and the ruling
of european cult of uh justice that will
uh
be published that morning the commission
president from the line is not taking
place in this debate it's at four in the
afternoon should we
will be replaced by um commissioner han
my question is she's in mob work on that
day uh that's some event organized by
buying tech twice can you tell us at
what time she's supposed to be there
thank you
thank you very much for the question
oliver because that actually provides me
the opportunity to give me the
opportunity to provide a few updates
regarding uh the president's
activities uh this week well you know
that we are living in some very volatile
uh times um and uh in view of the
overall situation the agenda of the
president is subject to
changes and indeed a last-minute
development that i am
going to inform you about is that the
president is no longer traveling
to marburg
it is an important event uh indeed
taking place there uh it's an event
about vaccine equity in relation uh to
africa we have discussed at length on
friday the importance that the
commission uh devotes to uh uh to to
this topic uh but in view of uh the uh
developing situation the president uh
can uh uh no longer travel instead she
will uh contribute differently uh she
will send
important messages uh route our
important messages around this topic
through a video message
um and indeed you also
mentioned oliver that the debate on the
rule of law conditionality
mechanism taking place in the afternoon
for that debate the commission will be
represented by commissioner han
he is the commissioner in charge of that
instrument it is his file so the
commissioner indeed uh according to uh
current planning will be taking place
himself in that debate
oliver i think you have a follow-up
question go ahead
very much so thank you um
so if she doesn't have to go to marble
why is she not going to strasbourg
this is quite an important
topic i would assume uh not only me in
german we have the beautiful word chef
sake which i think is also well
understood in all the other languages
secondly what's the important uh
development that keeps her from going to
my artwork and where is she going to be
physically is you're going to be in in
brussels or where thank you
thank you for your questions oliver so
indeed the current planning is that the
president uh returns returns from
strasbourg uh to brussels
tomorrow evening after the um
meeting of the college of uh
commissioners uh there
um and
according to her current plan according
to current planning she will be
indeed uh
in brussels uh on wednesday
well uh oliver you're asking me what is
uh the situation uh or what what are the
events which um would keep the president
uh busy with other things uh you are of
course um aware of the
uh
debates and the evolutions um regarding
uh among others uh the situation uh in
ukraine
i have to reassure you that the
president follows very closely
development in relation to the rule of
law conditionality mechanism and rule of
law
in general
are there any additional questions about
this subject
yes lily go ahead
um thank you i had to follow up on this
since the president will already be in
strasbourg are you concerned that this
move to come back early to brussels and
to skip the rule of law debate could
create a perception that the president
is not prioritizing democracy in rule of
law in europe thank
you thank you very much for your
question lily the president is
prioritizing a rule of law
of course development around the
conditionality mechanism on which we
expect an important court ruling this
wednesday
and i believe that the president has had
plenty of opportunities to convey the
strong importance that she attaches to
the subject
in discussions both with
eu leaders
when she addresses
leaders from the countries concerned by
these debates she has made her points
very clear in discussions in the
european parliament i referred to the
many debates that we had
one of those being
an important debate that we
had i think in october
in the parliament's uh plenary also
in strasbourg so i believe that the
commission um has shown its strong
credentials in terms of investments um
on the rule of law uh subject in terms
of action but also in terms of
participation to debates
are there any additional questions in
relation to this topic
so please at this stage only keep your
hand up
if you have questions about this
moses is your question about this
yes tala it's about
the debate on the rule of law
on wednesday following the decision by
european court of voters the european
court of justice and my question is how
fast
does the commission think that
draft guidelines
which commission has presented to be in
consumptive european parliament how
thoughts can they be finalized now
after that
decision
and is it the commission's opinion that
my second question
if the mechanism can be activated even
before the guidelines have been finally
finalized and adopted by the council
thank you
thank you very much
for your question moses you will of
course understand that we are not going
to elaborate on the steps that we are
going to take in relation to
the implementation of the conditionality
mechanism before we have the court
ruling on the conditionality mechanism
itself
we will
wait uh of course to see uh what the
court says in relation to the legality
of uh the mechanism and depending on the
court's position
and ruling we will
need to uh
to uh adjust perhaps uh just let me
reassure that the commission will
proceed as quickly as possible depending
uh to to implement and to apply um
the uh
that the effects of that ruling in place
but of course we cannot elaborate on any
of those steps beforehand
oliver you have a follow-up question on
this
hi thanks sorry
if she's already in strasbourg for the
commission college meeting uh why
doesn't she stay there for another day
and take part in this very important
debate herself represent the commission
which business
is so uh important and
can't be conducted from her office in
strasbourg she is a fully fledged
commission office in the parliament as
well most of her office is as we all
know now of her work is now conducted
through phone calls
and uh telephonic short messages anyway
why can't you do it into taskbar before
she heads down to the plenary
and you know represent the commission is
she afraid
of facing the parliament
on the rule of law in this matter thank
you
thank you very much for your question
oliver to which i already answered but i
would be happy to give it another go
perhaps additional clarity on my site
will provide you a more satisfactory
resolution to these questions so the
president is happy to engage on the
issues of rule of law with the european
parliament as she has done in the past i
mentioned only the most recent debates
that we had in the european uh
parliament in relation to that topic
according to current planning
it is the member of the college in
charge of this file commissioner han
who will be representing the commission
in that important debate the president
will of course follow uh very closely
the evolutions and in particular of
course
[Music]
the
aftermath of the
ecj ruling on that
the president has many important files
to uh continue work on
um as you know
she is fully busy working uh jointly
with
peers so with eu leaders
as well as
other allies um including transatlantic
allies uh with regards to the situation
um unfolding um in and around ukraine
so that is a file on which the president
and all
relevant members of the college are
fully focusing
and as you know there will be an
important uh summit also following in
the second
part of this week
the eu africa summit so i can assure you
that the president will be
very busy and she will also follow very
closely the debates on the rule of law
that you refer to
moses i think you have a follow-up
question on this
donna
okay i can i can understand that the
president must focus on the ongoing
situation
in ukraine and russia and the risk of
imminent invasion by russia took into
account ukraine and that deserves i
suppose her intention now and the
question is then i mean if the
commission has an opinion about this
issue about the
possible ukraine membership not only in
the european union in future
we work on that i suppose but also in
nato
the issue which is so controversial
and which perhaps is used as a pretext
by
reason let's say by russia to
for his policies and to threaten
invasion
what is i mean has a commission an
opinion on that and if if that is the
case is that the movement say to state
that clearly in order to try in the last
minute
to avoid and prevent
a war
thank you
very much for your
question moses which is wide and complex
i think that we have made
very clear
up to this point
as often as we could our unwavering
support
uh for ukraine as an important part of
the partner of the european union we had
on friday a large discussion about our
wide-ranging support uh a a broad
discussion here in the press reliant uh
with many of your colleagues about our
wide-ranging support to ukraine and
about the network of partnerships
which
link us which bind uh ukraine and the
european union together if you wish to
reignite that discussion and to have
once more stated
our opposition in relation to ukraine
and the rights of
ukrainian people to decide on their
alliances and security arrangements i
would be more than happy to call peter
on stage once more uh to to provide a
broader and more detailed answer
and peter will be joining us
yes
thank you honestly
i don't know what's what's what's there
to add i mean we said everything about
the situation as we see it now
developing and evolving in in the
context of the russia ukraine crisis the
diplomatic engagement continues for us
the diplomatic engagement is the most
important part of coordinated joint
international efforts conducted at
various levels at the levels of
ministers prime ministers leaders etc
etc we are in constant touch with our
partners both in ukraine and uh
within the european union at the other
side of the atlantic and we continue to
work hand in hand towards the escalation
of the situation and finding
peaceful resolution of the problem
thank you are there any additional
questions about ukraine yes please go
ahead
it's actually more about russia
the president after the call with
president biden on friday mentioned
possible sanctions against the
energy sector in of russia so could you
be
more precise on that thank you thank you
very much
as president wonderlion has said uh many
times and as you have also read
as you rightly rightly point out in the
readout following the video conference
with president biden
we are working
on a vast on a robust and comprehensive
package of sanctions
economic sanctions financial sanctions
sanctions of different nature that we
will introduce swiftly against russia
should russia
continue to escalate
in and basically uh
act any aggression against ukraine
i will not be able to go into the
specifics of those sanctions and it
belongs to the nature of sanctions that
one doesn't discuss in detail publicly
about
all those aspects just it is important
to
to know that those sanctions uh that
were very well advanced on the
preparation
of that package of sanctions that we are
coordinated with our allies and we will
be uh ready to introduce them rapidly
should that be required but no details
that it can be shared in the public
domain
beforehand
any other questions regarding sanctions
or
russia in general
ruff you have your hand up so go ahead
yes uh hi everyone it's it's also a
question uh about ukraine uh actually i
mean we have the threat of war uh
hanging uh in the air and
you know within days there could be uh
war refugees uh spilling into
up to four uh european union nations i
just wondered if you could guide us a
little bit through the preparedness of
the european uh union to uh accommodate
potential war refugees
to what extent uh funds have already
been earmarked to go into that effort to
support countries like poland and
hungary that will be facing this if you
could help us on that thank you
thank you very much for your question i
understand that the questions for peter
uh have attached to their end today so
indeed we can then move on to
to the subject of preparedness so indeed
the second track of your of our work
in addition to
work on the package of sanction is that
of preparedness
so
we have been uh working on preparedness
in a wide ranging ranging sense
uh covering all possible aspects which
could be which could unfold uh should
the situation further escalate
and indeed migration and refugees is one
of the areas which are covered by our
preparedness
efforts um but there is nothing specific
and in detail that we can share
beforehand
just that
we will be ready for anything that
happens in this area and in others and
we will work very closely with our
member states in order to provide
the operational support that will be
necessary at any stage
rough you have a follow-up question
no
no
for that i just wondered to what extent
this is already happening now thank you
thank you ralph the process of
preparedness of is gone ongoing so we
are working and we have been working on
uh preparedness for um a longer time the
aim being of being ready for anything
that happens anytime that happens
thank you any additional questions for
us today on any other topic
yes nawab go ahead
yazana thank you i have a question
actually for peter on afghanistan
and the question is as follows
there are media reports that a meeting
will take place in doha today
between the taliban and other countries
or organizations including the eu so can
you confirm this
and can you tell us more details about
this thank you
thank you this is normally for nabil but
nobody is also i'm replacing her and
this is what i can tell you is i can
confirm that there will be an meeting
like you described the inter-service
delegation of the european union led by
eu special representative for
afghanistan is uh in doha because the
meeting will take place in qatar who is
generously hosting another meeting uh
related to afghanistan and they will
hold a meeting with the taliban
representatives and the de facto
authorities of afghanistan tomorrow
15th of february um you know that the
european union and its member states
have decided on a set of benchmarks
which are guiding our engagement with
the de facto authorities in afghanistan
and
they continue to serve as guiding
principles for our engagement this
engagement is in no way recognition of
the de facto authorities and
the
interaction with the with the taliban in
this context is focused on uh making
sure that we can continue delivering for
afghan for organic people that means we
will raise in the meeting among other
things the right to education of of
girls and boys arbitrary detentions
unlawful arrests restrictions on media
and media freedom freedom of assembly
humanitarian access and steps towards an
inclusive government and inclusive
governance in afghanistan again uh we
will be
talking to the taliban representatives
and to the de facto authorities along
the benchmarks which have been set by
the by the member states and the
engagement is in no way recognition of
the authorities it is necessary in order
to be able to deliver um the necessary
assistance to the afghani people
thank you are there any additional
questions for peter on afghanistan
first nawab you have a follow-up
question go ahead
yes peter about these benchmarks
have you set a time limit for the
taliban to accept them and say okay you
have to accept this in these four in
months or weeks or we stop all
cooperation with you
thank you
it's not really a policy of the european
union to set tough deadlines but this is
the message that we are continuing to
deliver to our counterparts in order if
you want to engage with us have a
cooperation and develop the cooperation
then these are the guidelines which will
be guiding our engagement with you so
they know it very clearly and we
continue to deliver
this message to them at every occasion
thank you
are there any additional questions for
pisa on
afghanistan
i see that
mass has his hand up but i wonder if
it's afghanistan but i see no other
request for
asking questions about this so yes must
go ahead i hope at least it's for peter
voyager
[Music]
peter so that's it first
sorry it's not for peter i took my hand
down
it's for ariana competition
well very good so then i'm going to free
peter once more and we're going to get
your question uh david because you are
now online
so ariana uh
yeah it's a question about the reports
last week
about qatar energy qatar petroleum there
was an investigation
about destination clauses restricting
uh supplies of lng obviously this is
really important with what's going on in
ukraine russia
i was wondering those reports suggest
that the
investigation is being closed or being
wrapped down could you deny those
reports or could you say the
investigation is still ongoing um
and has there been some change i mean
because
you know obviously we need to secure the
gas supplies um
destination has there been some
some change in the way destination
clauses are being considered by the
commission given the
the need for gas supplies thanks
thank you very much and ariana is today
dan uh who is replacing her and is ready
to give you an answer i hope yes
absolutely thanks uh dan i'm an irish
version of ariana today um
thanks david for your question as i'm
sure you can well imagine at this point
we have no comment to make on the press
reports in um just by way of background
in 2018 the commission opened an
investigation to assess whether supply
agreements between qatar energy
companies exporting liquefied natural
gas and european importers have hindered
the free flow of gas within the economic
european economic area in breach of eu
antitrust rules since then we here in
the commission have engaged in extensive
fact-finding to determine whether
certain clauses contained in those
agreements may prevent or limit the
resale of lng within the internal market
in breach of article 101 of the treaty
the in-depth investigation is ongoing
and we cannot prejudge its outcome or
timing at this moment in time
thank you very much are there any
additional questions for
dan or ariana on competition related
issues
what i see nikolas stand up but i wonder
if it's a question about that
no it's for peter so peter will be back
the third time
um and in the meantime i um
i check if daniel um has a question for
dan ariana because his hand is up
as well
so keep your hands sorry my question was
for peter too
so then i will free done thank you and
if you do not mind i will try to go back
to uh tomas
because he was keen to ask a question
in relation to senegal and frontex
and i stopped him in order to prioritize
questions which were actually for ariana
so mass if you're still there
now is the time to ask your question
about senegal
negotiations
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
x
[Music]
context
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
there
she
[Music]
uh
uncertainty
i'm really sorry i don't have a question
for peter anymore uh i wanted to
talk about my great brain against maybe
it's rather for other bit i don't know
um i know that one of my previous
speakers
already asked about the preparations for
possible fight movements
um i would really like to talk about
what these
uh preparations
uh look like uh specifically and so for
example there's talk about one million
ukrainian
countries who could make their way um to
the fourth forehaven countries my
question is are the current facilities
sufficient to accommodate these refugees
is there any additional help for example
of financial nature
and i would also like to know if uh or
to what extent
the current developments changed the
general debate on migration in the eu
so for example could we rethink
the distribution of migrants
to the eu thank you
thank you so much so once more i free
peter
because there is not a question for him
uh indeed and it's no longer a question
for adelberg either because he changed
portfolios he is now
the happy spokesperson in charge of
environmental matters and and others and
anita uh takes care of
uh migration and security measures
however you may be referring to what i
myself said in relation to preparedness
a few minutes ago
so in relation to that allow me to
reiterate once more that we are fully
focused on finding
a diplomatic solution and to achieve the
escalation in relation to the situation
in and around ukraine so this is the big
priority all efforts
are focused on that
secondly should a diplomatic solution
fail
we are ready and we will be ready and we
are working on being ready um through
preparedness efforts on all possible
strands
be it energy
be it
a migration
on the economic side however we are not
going to elaborate more at this stage on
what happened if in relation to none of
these scenarios
the second question was indeed about
migration and how
possible developments in relation to
ukraine
may impact the debate that we have on
migration the answer there is very clear
and the answer is on the table
it is the pact on migration and asylum
which the european commission
put forward more than one year ago
it is a package
which regards
migration comprehensively seeking to
achieve the best balance between an
effective and a humane way to address a
migration by looking at strengthening
and fine-tuning all the instruments that
we have in relation to migration be it
a silent procedure or reception
conditions or return procedures
or border procedures for death matter so
the answer to strengthen the union's
migration policy is on the table it's
the pact on migration and we are
exhorting the member states to continue
making progress and discussions on that
to enable us to have an effective
migration policy
oliver you have a question which i
assume it's related to that
go ahead
yes hi thank you
i mean on your migration and the silent
package uh will i mean that in a sense
is moved to a certain degree since the
french
presidency decided to
uh unwrap it and deal with several
subjects in individually whereas you the
commission would like to have it all
dealt with in one package but that's
just an side comment on your
presentation of the political uh debate
more concretely on ukraine is the
commission discussing
thoughts about topping up humanitarian
aid to ukraine because um
these people who are probably seeing or
thinking about fleeing won't come to
europe they'll probably go to western
ukraine so are you thinking about
topping up eight four for echo and four
for any other of your your eight
organizations thank you
thank you very much uh oliva indeed many
thanks for allowing me to to talk about
that as well indeed any humanitarian
needs are of course covered by our
discussions about preparedness because
again as i said
we are
working on preparedness with the view to
be prepared for
anything that may happen anytime it may
happen
are there any additional questions for
us today on this matter or on other
matters
i do not see any hands up so
thank you very much do not forget about
the technical briefing on the space
package which is going to
to start very rapidly so stay connected
and of course remember that tomorrow the
college readout will be at 3 30 and it
will take place from strasbourg thank
you and have a good day